[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: In this
goodie bag, we'll
be exploring atomic
packing and solids
through the cubic
Bravais lattices.
We'll make three ball-and-stick
models of different cubic unit
cells.
For this, you will need
31 balls and 44 sticks--
24 for FCC, 12 for
SC, and 8 for BCC.
If you don't have a fancy
crystal modeling kit like this,
any ball-and-stick
equivalents will work.
A delicious alternative
would be using
toothpicks and marshmallows.
The objective of
the goodie bag is
to explore the
different structures
of crystalline materials.
As you build the models,
consider how many
nearest neighbors an atom has
in an SC, a BCC, and an FCC
crystal.
So now we're going to
construct our Bravais lattices.
We'll start with simple cubing.
Begin by taking 8 balls
and connecting them with
sticks such that each ball
sits at the corner of a cube.
Then for body-centered
cubic, we're
going to start with a single
ball in the center of a cube
and connect to 8 other balls
at the corners with sticks.
For face-centered
cubic, it's going
to be a little more involved.
We'll start with the corner
of a cube and form tetrahedra
to other balls, which
themselves will form tetrahedra
to another corner of a cube.
If we iterate
through this process,
we eventually end up with a full
face-centered cubic lattice.
We've now constructed
three ball-and-stick models
of cubic Bravais lattices.
The simple cubic
lattice has atoms
at each of the 8 corners
of the unit cell.
The body-centered cubic
lattice has an additional atom
in the body center
of the unit cell.
And the face-centered
cubic lattice
has an additional atom
in each of the 6 face
centers of the unit cell.
Each of these lattices has a
different coordination number.
That is, an atom in each
lattice has a different number
of nearest neighbors.
If we imagine these
atoms as hard spheres
rather than this
ball-and-stick model,
we can see that each
lattice will also
have a different
atomic packing factor.
That is, each lattice will have
a different volume of space
occupied in the unit cell.
In general, the coordination
number of a lattice
correlates with atomic
packing factor, which itself
correlates with stability.
That's why we don't often find
simple cubic metallic solids
in nature.